this morning we're learning more about
two men accused of pretending to be
federal agents and giving financial
favors to secret service officials
including a member of first lady jill
biden's protective detail prosecutors
say this alleged scheme lasted for more
than two years but they haven't revealed
a motive senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge is
following this story catherine good
morning well good morning federal
prosecutors told the court the men are a
flight risk citing possible links to
pakistani intelligence and recent travel
to iran and the judge agreed to hold
them pending a detention hearing later
today these images show the suspects
ariane taharzadeh and haider ali
surrounded then arrested by federal law
enforcement on wednesday two law
enforcement sources tell cbs news ali
had been under investigation in new
jersey by homeland security and the u.s
postal service concerning an alleged
credit card ring yesterday prosecutors
revealed evidence seized from the
suspect's luxury d.c apartments
including ballistic vests gas masks
handheld radios and a drone court
documents indicate tahrzadeh had gained
access to the security system for the
entire apartment complex which houses
many residents affiliated with federal
law enforcement agencies to win over
agents the suspect's alleged gifts
included rent-free apartments at a cost
of at least forty thousand dollars a
year iphones and a flat screen tv one
suspect offered to buy a two thousand
dollar assault rifle for a secret
service agent assigned to the first
lady's protective detail the secret
service says all personnel involved are
on administrative leave a former fbi
agent tells cbs news it appears to be a
significant security lapse by a handful
of agents and the amount of money
involved suggests the suspects had
outside support tony
all right catherine thank you very much